sa carrière en annoncer quand même un
petit peu rapide arrivée à être face à
redire ou danon vous trouvez pas moi je
trouve que c'est râpé c'est même trop
rapide parce que c'est pas maintenant
qu'on peut arriver à apprendre le métier
de 15 ans
il ya deux ans je chantais pas du tout
il ya beaucoup de chanteurs d'artistes
qui avant que sa marge ont travaillé
beaucoup sur les planches pendant les
cas pareils jours comme ça dit comment
liu
m
pas de soleil
qui
sur terre
il
car elles sont
les tons
emmanuel hardy vous êtes tout seul là
sur votre petit banc expliquez-moi
pourquoi vous n'êtes ni avec ses
camarades
si ni avec ses camarades là est ce que
vous êtes contre laurie pour le
romantisme ou le contraire je suis entre
les deux justement c'est la raison vous
êtes entre les deux oui qu'est ce que ça
veut dire que je pense que je fais des
chansons dont les paroles sur 12 est
dans l'air est quand même un petit peu
mais chaque grain du jeu
la peau
qui se faire
vous êtes romantique un peu vous avez
souvent rêver au prince charmant tout le
monde
11h17 mélancolie dans vos yeux et dans
vos chansons
c'est sans doute l'expression de votre
âge de votre tempérament
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est aussi
l'expression chanter d'une époque où
tout au moins d'une génération
moi je pense alors que les gens de ma
génération
oubliant toutes les époques des moments
de cafard et d'une joie et puis qu'ils
ont on aime les retrouver dans les
chansons bien dans des poèmes
tournez-vous il ya quelque chose qui
m'intrigue vous avez mis votre chandail
à l'envers exprès parce que trop grand
mais c'est une idée de mode saas est
joli joli
enfin merci musée la merci